NARRATOR: This photo looks
like a scene straight out
of "Game of Thrones."
The large army, the blazing
fire, the medieval weapons--
like they're preparing
for some grand battle.
But this photo was taken
only a couple of years ago,
and, I mean, Westeros
isn't in real place.
The person watching these
marching men was this woman.
ALICE HEYWOOD: My
name is Alice Heywood,
and I grew up in
California, but I've
lived in Edinburgh for 17 years,
and I work in digital learning
at the National
Library of Scotland.
I'm also a keen, but very
amateur, photographer.
This photo was taken in
Lerwick, or as the natives would
call it, Lare-ick, on
the Shetland Islands
in Scotland at the start of
the Up Helly Aa festival.
NARRATOR: For 24 hours on the
last Tuesday of every January,
the Up Helly Aa Fire
Festival commences
on the Shetland Islands
off the coast of Scotland.
The event, which began in
1870, celebrate the island's
Scandinavian Viking heritage.
Up to 1,000 men from the
islands parade with burning
torches around the
streets of Lerwick,
while hundreds of people,
like Alice, gather to watch.
ALICE HEYWOOD: The
Shetland Islands
didn't become part of Scotland
until the 15th century,
and so this festival
celebrates these Viking roots.
The men you see this photograph
are dressed in Viking costumes
compete with helmets
and axes, all of which
they get custom made
especially for this day.
The men make up the
Jarl Squad, or Earl,
as he would be known
in English, and they're
the only ones who get the
privilege of dressing up
like Vikings.
The rest of the men make up some
of the 40 to 50 other squads,
each of whom dress up
with a particular theme.
This can range from the
wacky to the outrageous,
from farmers to drag queens,
and everything in between.
NARRATOR: And they
don't stop there.
Each year, the Jarl Squad
builds a replica Viking ship
and hauls it along the
head of the procession,
while the rest of the men
throw their torches into it.
Everyone watches it burn while
singing the traditional chant
and cheering amidst the flames.
ALICE HEYWOOD: The party
then gets under way,
which lasts all night.
And when I mean all night,
I literally mean all night.
NARRATOR: The Scottish
know how to party,
but more than that, they know
what it means to have pried,
to recognize their roots,
and that's worth celebrating.
ALICE HEYWOOD: It's a truly
spectacular event that
recalls the important cultural
and historic ties to Norway,
but it's also very distinct to
Shetland and Scotland, which
is what I love most about it.
NARRATOR: Hey, everyone,
thanks for watching
"This Happened Here."
If you liked this episode,
be sure to check out
this one on a controversial
sex float in the Netherlands.
SUBJECT 2: This float was made
by the district Veldstraat
from Zundert.
The designer wanted to
do something different
from the nice or funny scenes,
and cause some discussion
without being vulgar.
NARRATOR: So he made a float
about censorship Thanks
for watching.